Bob Kravitz the athletic senior staff
reporter and has been covering Indiana
sports for a long time where does this
rank on top stories that you've covered
in Indiana sports history first let me
just say I am NOT a millennial but I am
the owner/operator of two of them this
is number one you know we were at a ball
game when we found out that Brad Stevens
had taken a job with the Boston Celtics
so that was up there you know the brawl
that was up there but as far as where
the hell did this come from what is
going on what has happened to our lives
this is numero uno no question about it
because this I thought that he might not
be a long time er honestly as I've come
to know him over the years and as the
injuries have have you know continued
but for the for it to happen just two
weeks before the season one has appeared
that he was on the right track to return
this is number one I said this about 15
minutes ago there are there are there
are football players but then there are
also people who play football and I
think Andrew Luck feels like a person
who plays football not a football player
does that make sense
well you know we want our athletes to be
well-rounded you know we want them to
have interests outside of the sports
they play and that that's Andrew I mean
Andrew cares about architecture he cares
about the world we've had conversations
about that the political ramifications
of you know different soccer games you
know Barcelona versus Madrid and all
that kind of stuff he cared about stuff
outside of football it doesn't suggest
that he loved or loves the game any less
than somebody else and say a Quentin
Elsinore or whomever you might come up
with but he is a guy who is multifaceted
you know he stayed in college a fourth
year when everybody knew he could have
come out just you know after his junior
year he's been after a South warrior
so he's just a different cat and you
know I think we all recognize that from
the start if you had one question for
luck today over to be when you coming
back did do you think he's coming back
you know I my colleagues from the
Athletics D folder and and sakti frog TV
last night they both think that he's
done I don't think that he's done just
the way Pat McAfee was ready to come
back Pat back if you retired at the age
of 29 as well and I always felt that at
some point Pat would think about
returning and he was considering a
return you know specifically the Chicago
Bears where they've got 27 different
guys you know trying out for the kicker
spot I do think that Andrew Luck at some
point is going to start feeling really
good physically and emotionally and I I
may be in the minority here but I have
this weird feeling that at some point we
may see Andrew Luck again we may see him
in a Colts uniform I don't know I'm sure
they they did this but I my initial
thought was laughter the shock then I
went I wonder if they could have said to
him take the first four weeks off or
take the first half of the season off
get healthy mentally physically like it
this wasn't a knee-jerk reaction though
knowing Andrew Luck it feels like he
didn't just decide this in the last you
know week to ten days
Bobby I absolutely know this has been
going on for quite a while is that
generous a you know I made some comments
about how he's had conversations with
Andrew in the past and when he says the
past I don't think he's talking about
the last week and a half about talking
him out of retiring and I got the sense
I have to listen to the tape so the
third time that he was suggesting that
they had these conversations when he had
the initial shoulder situation and look
he was considering walking away from the
game when he was going through the
shoulder thing so you know somebody at
the you know are you surprised about
this and yeah I'm surprised in the
timing but I really thought that in the
long term if this ever happened again he
may not he may say you know the hell
with this you know it's just not worth
it and you know he's he's newly married
he's got a child on the way I believe in
November so you know he's got other
things too on his plate and I just I I
give him credit you know I look I as a
somebody who consumes sports writes
about sports you know I loved watching
him play he was you know one of the top
players in the league and I think he had
a chance to be an MVP sometime the next
two or three years if he could have
stayed healthy and certainly behind this
offensive line you had every reason to
believe things were going to get a lot
better but at the same time Danny I'm
sure you saw some of the press
conference he's exhausted
he is so completely emotionally
exhausted I don't know if it rises to
the level of clinical you know a
clinical type of depression or
what-have-you but he is really tired and
down and this process has taken so much
out of him I just don't know what's left
for football or anything else for that
matter what's your reaction to the
National media's reaction to the
Indianapolis fans reaction at the game
Andrew Luck announced his retirement to
process all those things I don't blame
the fans because first of all there was
a lot left of them it was a preseason
game the people who stuck around to the
end to boot him were probably people who
had a few cocktails because if you're in
a preseason game until the fourth
quarter chances are you know you have
been drinking apple juice and I just
think they were confused they felt
betrayed I don't
I wrote my column that it was wrong it
was the wrong response but at the same
time I completely understand and it's
not an Indianapolis thing it's not a
Boston thing son Chicago thing I
think that you know they've been sort of
they feel like they've been toyed with
now from last two three years with all
this stuff
and I just think they were it was a
sense of betrayal and a sense of
complete confusion and I would bet you
that if you took a hundred those people
who were booing and had them watch his
press conference afterwards I would bet
you a good percentage of them would wish
that they had not food that there was a
real reason for what happened a real
thought thought that went into this
whole thing let's end it with this
Jacoby brusett will be what average I
think he's I think he's easy they think
he's a top 20 quarterback okay now what
does that mean seven and nine eight and
eight six and ten you know they have a
pretty good team around them I don't
know how good he is I don't think we can
reach any conclusions based on what he
did two years ago when he you know
rolled into town literally had to learn
the entire offense in the flight never
acted that the playbook completely had
was surrounded by a terrible team that
ultimately went for it 12
coaching staff wasn't good this time
he's got a really good coaching staff
great offensive line good people on the
outside he's got an approved defense so
they ought to be competitive I don't
know they're a playoff team with Andrew
Luck not only were they a playoff team I
thought they were a Super Bowl contender
so I think they move on and don't make
the decision at the end of the year do
they move forward with Jacoby Brissette
or do they you know tank for tua
good stuff Bob good to check in with you
hope you're doing well and good luck
with the athletic okay thanks so much
Dan Bob Kravitz
senior staff reporter for the athletic
forum or Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]